hallo mein name ist luca meiner lieben
frau kommt zu einem neuen video genau
[Gelächter]
meine lieben freunde das was wir gerade
machen dürfen wir heute dass wir gerade
schon so fleißig gemacht haben dürfen
dem heutigen video eigentlich nicht mal
herzlich willkommen ja heute zu einer
neuen nicht lachen challenge auf meinem
kanal dass ich an die letzten male mega
coup ich anfangen würde ich sagen rief
direkt mit dem ersten video ja drei
jahre
[Musik]
ich bin ich bin kein passwort bei denen
nur drei versuche hast mir hat es nur
ein
wieder so richtig richtige instagram bio
weise lokomotiven west
dass kartoffeln herzen gut bekommen
wir können uns noch mal so erschreckten
keine andere 2000 jahre später
bedeutungsschwanger sonst bestehen von
anfang an bitte bitte schon mal
grundsätzlich vorschicken versucht aber
ich bin es geht bei solchen leuten nicht
alt sie betont dass so wie hier klar
dass eine krankheit wäre
ich glaube in dem moment selbst hätte
man es gar nicht so lustig gefunden aber
dadurch dass man es jetzt die ganze zeit
7 2 wobei so weit über 70 oder fragen ob
die ich hoch kommenden drei jahre mit
mir machen
dies würde dafür auch eine packung
haribo gekommen und das ist irgendwie
auch unglaublich das war dreck hier war
vorne so weit du morgen sehr geil drauf
sein
[Musik]
tja ich finde tiere irgendwie nützlich
also ich bin dir ja wie witzig
unterstützen wollt das ist in
lichtensteig wochen habe ich kriege ich
mit google geld also und alles was sie
mich zu unterstützen
wenn wir hier meine videos gucken egal
was das ksk tricks gestürzt es ist
tricks gestützt
du musst immer bachelor witzigsten
szenen cook nicht über das ist tot
lachen
ich habe mir das mal betrunken gegeben
ich habe mir in die hosen gepackt so
wird sie ja das alter das in san ramon
das hier ist anderer dann vom fernseher
quasi sind unglaublich hässlich was ist
der sinn
dieses kostüm aus noch hässlicher mir
was du an karneval habe angst davor dass
ich durch rassismus irgendwelche
nachteile erleiden muss
frauenfeindlichkeit und gewalt vor alten
und neuen vorurteilen und rassismus
spinnen und insekten weil die trabant
ist ja wohl noch weiter für nicht aber
gut meine damen und herren an der stelle
würden sander und ich das heutige wir
jetzt auch beenden wenn euch diese nicht
lachen können würde ich gern noch mal
erwähnen dass wir mit unserem podcast
dick und doof nominiert sind für den
deutschen podcast preis wie wir das
geschafft haben weiß ich auch nicht
ich weiß auch nicht warum zeigt dein
auge und auch nie gegen die ah ja wir
sind auf jeden fall nominiert für den
deutschen podcast preis in links unten
in der video beschreibung also klickt
dort gern drauf man muss sich dann nicht
anmelden oder irgendwas muss einfach nur
auf abstimmen klicken das wird uns sehr
freuen
das sei wie gesagt einen daumen hoch
beim video da abonniert main kanal war
zwar kein teil der lupus shop bei sandra
vorbei dies auch in der beschreibung
verlinkt und du hast die letzten sieben
worte
die geister aus deutschland
[Musik]